[Music]
good night good night
yes yes yes good night
[Music]
there are a lot of other villains in the
world but i am going to be
a super
[Music]
child villain you can be a villain i am
pretty despicable
all right all right i'm not minnie
please stop calling me that
time to strike
[Music]
my minions will save me
you like picking on little guys huh i am
a master of kung-fu
for smoochie smoochie
i will teach you
ah here kevin kevin
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
why don't we make this a fair fight
um
[Music]
you only get one shot
[Music]
i see
[Music]
what do you drive
i got the jet bike
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
everybody here for the interview
me too
what do you drive
i got the jet bike they're ready to see
you mr crew oh god great
[Music]
here we go
distinguished villains
my name is cru
i feel like i'm talking too loud even
though our proximity doesn't require
this kind of volume
you seriously think a puny little child
can be a villain
yes i am pretty despicable you don't
want to cross me
come back when you've got something evil
to impress me
[Music]
i'll distract them
this is the biggest day of
[Applause]
this
my
just stole something from the world's
villains in the world
time to strike now i will be a super
villain
now all i need is otto where is ato
are you pulling on my legs right now
otto where's the stone oh
foreign
[Music]
did you just trade my future
for a petra
oh i didn't mean to scare you now
where's groom
[Music]
you